it's it sounds like to do the stuff you
do you have to like search up some
pretty dodgy [ __ ]
what's what's like the weirdest thing
you've had to search up on Google that's
to do what you do there's a lot of
people's search history I want to look
through it yours is definitely the top
of the list I don't know I just got you
like I said I just search anything I
don't really think too much of it and
you've never ever been contacted by like
a government agency about anything what
once oh it was so it was really mundane
okay okay I'd love to hear anyway so
what's weird about Canada too is like I
finally just don't really they're not
super strict on a lot of stuff in the US
I probably would not be able to have the
same YouTube channel yeah yeah really
they just raid you for math like every
week are you serious yeah like I was on
a forum for a while and before I started
or before I really got like did YouTube
a lot there's a science Forum or
chemistry it's called science Madness
yeah and it's like a lot of people just
talk about how they just would knock on
your door they'll just swab everything
to see if there's you're making that and
but I've never been contacted like
four yeah anything I do yeah I did
always find interesting how like YouTube
has this kind of weird ecosystem where
stuff that would channels that could
only exist in a certain country yeah
yeah and not in others right yeah like
how there's a bunch of gun content on
for Americans it's like no other country
could ever make this type of content
exactly I think Canada is actually one
of the few places in the world that you
could have like a proper and there is
the uh explosions in fire uh the
Australian guy oh yeah
I'm sure he likes being described as the
Australian what do they contact you
about the government it was just I
literally it's because I it's actually
meth related but it was not not
methrelated in the sense that they
thought I was making that yeah I just
bought a really big funnel and like so
in in chemistry that's great that's good
chemistry there's like there's two
levels of I guess like glassware and
just just scale okay so when you do
research people call like it's not
really a term that people use I guess
but this one
I don't really know if there's a proper
term but you'd be like quantities that
you do research with okay so usually sub
a gram right right so like maybe up to
five grams no no usually it's like a
gram and Below okay a lot of research
chemistry is like milligrams yeah okay
oh so if you're buying anything more
than aggressive no it's just expensive
okay and a lot of the chemicals are
expensive you're just you do you're
wasting money you're just wasting money
and resources and you get the same
answer anyway but the moment you think
you have a good reaction a lot of times
you have to scale it up so you do like
preparation so it's like preparative cap
which is a different thing because like
I'm working in beakers on like let's say
like 500 mils yeah 250 they're pretty
small yeah but sometimes people are like
my chemical I've used very dilute
conditions I don't make too much to make
let's say 10 grams I need to work with
like three liters yeah so you're no
longer in the one liter Beaker you're
kind of with like giant big things so
that's fine with beakers because they're
kind of just cups yeah but you start
getting the like the big funnels which
are very abnormal for like research chem
right so it's like most people who do
that are they're preparing chemicals
they're not researching they're like
synthesizing chemicals on a larger scale
for people to research with no oh like a
lot of people in research are trying to
just like as far as I know like prove
that their reaction could be scaled up
okay that makes sense and some people do
it on the preparative scale like uh
the chemical is like really expensive
but the two things that make that
chemical are cheap so they'll buy a lot
of that some of them will stockpile like
a kilo of what they need and that lasts
them like their entire research project
okay okay that makes sense but they
don't do it often and like often in like
some of the labs like the lab I worked
in you'd have like one of those funnels
or maybe maybe two and this one is
abnormal and sketchy it's just the fact
you're only using it to make large
amounts of chemicals and usually yeah
that's it I think you're just making a
larger scale not usually yeah okay so so
you buy it right and it's like yeah and
it's like a little bit specialized
because it's like a full glass like
vacuum funnel
the thing is that it's kind of like it's
used for math well in meth there's kind
of a I think it's a 22 liter round
bottom flask it's in Breaking I've heard
this thing
I swear I've heard that why what do you
mean are you gonna get the 22 liter
round bottom flash yeah so it's like
it's a it's literally a thing that in
the U.S in certain places you're just
not allowed buying it right or so if you
buy it it's like very suspicious since
breaking bad or since before breaking
it's just what are you doing with it
like why do you have to make so much of
it because it's just such a big you're
preparing so much of a chemical yeah
that like unless you work for like a
large-scale industrial synthesis company
why doesn't average why do you own this
right okay so so the moment you get past
a certain size and you're like a private
citizen yeah what in God's name could
they be doing with it but uranium fine
right just fine I'm okay honestly they
probably I don't remember where like I
said I don't remember exactly where the
uranium came from but probably if it's
like fully labeled and was shipped over
the border right
I did order from the U.S uranium it was
fully labeled and actually they didn't
say anything right so okay so you order
the the funnel online yeah it was a call
or what what is it it was a funnel like
it was like and you on like a website
eBay okay so you get on eBay right and
is it before it arrives right after it
arrives when does that when do they call
you I had it I think for like
I want to say like a week when they call
you up yeah I got a call from a guy and
the RCMP is the federal police in Canada
okay but the guy is just like yeah you
know I got a notice from like the
Customs uh that you bought a funnel oh
no you bought something and um I need to
follow up on it I promise I'm not making
messes I would be shitty but I could
tell that he was in a cruiser like in a
car right he was calling me driving yeah
yeah so and he said he goes yeah I get
follow-ups I have to like just follow up
on these things I need to know what
you're using it for and at first he
sounded very suspicious because like
he's like you bought it online I'm like
yeah and you can you know you get that
like from law enforcement you get that
oh yeah yeah
they're trying to like pin you something
yeah yeah like he's suspicious and then
I went oh well like you know I run a
YouTube channel and he's like YouTube
this is like 20 I wanna say 2017. yeah
he's like YouTube what do you do on that
channel and I was like oh I do chemistry
and if you he's like he's something you
I can look up and I'm like yeah yeah
everything I do is like publicly
available he goes oh okay uh yeah okay
anyway I just he immediately sounded
like you want to be off the phone you
got your channel you just see like no
he's a notepad open up today I'm going
to teach you how to make math
no he immediately sounded like he just
didn't want to be in the conversation
anymore and he was wrapping up and I
even said oh uh do you think it's a good
like should you want my channel name
music oh yeah that's probably a good
idea
just the moment that I even gave like a
reason that was half reasonable he was
like okay cool because I think most
people could literally not explain why
they have it yeah right right I would
hopefully order it I'll probably be
professionals yeah it's pretty very easy
for them to be like yeah I'm just doing
this yeah okay I said he's I think he's
like I said they're in my videos he goes
if I looked at I think he's like if you
if someone went and watched your videos
could they see this funnel I'm like yeah
yeah it's gonna be in one of these yeah
you have my word officer no he just
suddenly was like okay this sounds too
reasonable yeah whereas if I wasn't
doing any of that yeah like if I didn't
I feel like having a YouTube channel
where everything's so public is what has
this is what I'm using this is how much
uranium in my head actually the evidence
is there it's literally all the evidence
yeah so you'll just see exactly and some
people but you could be making meth
behind the scenes and it's like to me
that's like no it's the weirdest like
conspiracy thing where
I don't know if you'd follow this but
I've seen some conspiracy stuff where
it's like so dumb and everyone's like
well there's hiding in plain sight and
I'm like why would I build an entire
YouTube channel
I could just make math and not publicly
tell everyone I'm a chemist
but I I can't okay to be fair though be
pretty [ __ ] smart no but the amount
of work to make the videos
yeah
I just want to see the new Breaking Bad
awkward water white just like starts
like a YouTube channel or the irony
would be that you start that was the
cover yeah but then the YouTube channel
started making more than that yeah I'd
like to think so you just you just
phased out the mess
I mean there is a world where I could
compete yeah the irony is that like
you're yeah your YouTube is more
lucrative than math you're right water
white is small brain for [ __ ] buying
a car wash yes well we'll use the car
wash I could have made a YouTube channel
funnel the money yeah so I just I needed
to spend 10 million dollars on 10 liters
of bromine I mean what can I say yes
just buy really expensive chemicals that
you don't have to be using it's a
perfect cover-up I do buy a bunch of
extensive chemicals that I don't get
that tax bill down